So the hypothalamus is is an entity,
it's a group of functionally related
entities that are composed of groups of
functionally related entities,
but you know you can't start at the
highest level of detail and progress
forward.
So we're going to use shortcuts.
So anyways,
the hypothalamus isn't a very big brain
area but it's an important one and it's
sufficiently sophisticated so that if
you take a female cat and that there's an
important reason that it's female and
you take out basically it's whole brain,
the limbic system that's responsible
for emotions and the whole cortical cap.
So it basically has no brain
except for his final chord.
The hypothalamus.
And if you keep it in a relatively
closed environment you don't like like a
cage,
it pretty much acts like a normal cat.
It can do all the normal cat things.
It can,
it can engage in defensive aggression,
it can eat,
it can drink,
it can sleep.
It's Co,
it's conscious as you know in so far as
you can tell whether or not an animal is
conscious,
it's hyper exploratory,
which is extraordinarily peculiar because
last thing you would expect of a cap
with no brain would be
to be hyper exploratory.
Right?
It seems to be insanely curious about
everything and that's what that seems to
indicate is that it's
psychomotor exploratory system,
which is in fact grounded in the
hypothalamus is still active,
but it can't build up the memory
representations that would inhibit the
exploratory activity because basically
what you're doing when you explore is
you're taking something,
something complex and then your mapping.
It's responses in relationship to the
transformations of your body and in so far
as the set of transformations of your
body that you're likely to manifest,
say in this place,
have zero motivational relevance,
which is really what you're
hoping for most of the time.
Then you build up a representation
of the place that's,
that's part of that perceptual motor
hierarchy and it shuts off your curiosity
about it and then what you perceive
from then on end really is your
representation of the thing.
Rather than the thing itself.
And you're kind of happy about that
because it's easier to see what you've
already learned that it is
to see that thing itself.
Now things can get re novelized you know,
if someone acts very
peculiarly right beside you,
you're like the whole space around you
is going to get re novelized very rapidly
and your body would go
on alert because of that.
But Mick,
basically what you're doing is
learning in order to ignore,
right?
Because you want,
you want to pay attention
to everything all the time.
It's like that's,
that's a short path to exhaustion because
if everything's relevant than your
body goes on hyper alert and you
produce cortisol and you know,
you're ready for anything and there's,
that's kind of exciting.
But as a longterm survival strategy,
it's bad.
What you just don't have the energy to
maintain that for any length of time.
So part of the reason the cat is hyper
exploratory is because the systems that
mediate exploration are still intact as
long as it has a hypothalamus and some
of the rough underlying circuitry that
associates that with the motor output
system.
Um,
but I can't remember what it's explored.
So just stays hyper exploratory.
It's also hyper reactive
safety cues of aggression.
I would say like a hypothalamic
cat is a lot like a two year old,
you know,
and I mean that in the best possible way.
Um,
two year olds are extremely curious.
They're hyper exploratory.
They're very,
very reactive to stimuli.
You know,
they cry easily,
they laugh easily,
they run around easily.
They,
they get scared easily.
you know,
experienced pain easily.
So,
and it isn't until they build the
higher order structures in the,
in the,
you know,
perceptual motor hierarchy that that
all gets integrated and they're not so
reactive then they're nowhere near
as much fun at that point either,
you know,
but uh,
and so the female cat can,
can regulate its,
its water intake and it can
also engage in sexual activity.
Now a male cat can't do that.
It needs more brain than
just the hypothalamus because
it's more complicated to
sequence male sexual behavior.
So you can tell the difference
between a male cat with no court tax,
let's say it,
no limbic system and a female cat,
but pretty much only in that,
in that particularity.
So,
so,
you know,
so that's very interesting.
A,
because if you,
if you study neuropsychology and you're
taught by clinical neuropsychologist,
say,
or even neuropsychologists that
have a clinical background,
they're very cortical centric.
You know,
and I think it's,
it's part of your hangover.
We're,
we're,
you know,
since we got unseated from our
position at the center of the universe,
we've been,
you know,
rat rat radically running around trying
to figure out what it is that makes us
special in relationship to animals.
And we kind of cottoned
onto the idea that,
you know,
we have this big cortical cap and
especially the prefrontal Cortex,
and it's very large in
relationship to our body,
which,
which it is.
And that,
you know,
somehow that distinguishes
us from other animals,
which it does.
But,
but that's also led us into thinking that
the most recently evolved parts of the
brain are the most important.
It's like,
and,
and in some sense the smartest,
you know?
But there's a real error of presumption
there because you might also,
you might think instead that it's those
parts of the brain that evolution has
had the longest time to work on
that are in fact the smartest,
you know?
And they do take care of
all the heavy lifting.
You know,
your,
your consciousness isn't entrusted
with any of the heavy lifting.
You can fiddle around the edges with it,
but you're not going to be allowed
to do anything that's really PR,
you know,
that's really physiologically profound.
And it's a good thing because you just
don't have the intellectual capacity to
manage that kind of ongoing
physiological monitoring.
You know?
It's like you don't understand
your body if you're lucky,
the thing works and you can
ignore it roughly speaking,
you know?
But if it ever goes wrong,
good luck trying to
figure it out consciously.
You know?
I mean,
we're getting somewhere with that,
but it's very,
very difficult to do.